[MUSIC PLAYING]
I started shooting at the age
of 16, so about two years now.
I started urban exploring
about last summer
when I started
linking up with people
that shoot with the
[INAUDIBLE] and stuff
and kind of got into the
whole urban exploring scene.
I followed them on Instagram
because I liked their photos.
And I just hit them up and
asked them if they want a shoot.
That's how you meet new people,
and luckily the people I've met
are good friends of mine now.
Instagram really
helped me get together
with all the other people that
had the same kind of interests
as me.
And that wanted to like
urban explore New York City,
and then I would also
bring my camera along.
Back then when I first
started doing this,
I didn't really know
much about photography.
I did get a lot
of tips and tricks
from people I chill with and
hang out with that do photos.
I just bring my camera
and shoot on auto,
and eventually my friends
and people I've met
gained some pointers
and tips and tricks,
and I started shooting
a manual and learned
how to really use my camera
to its full potential.
Well, we met-- we
used to work together.
We met at a coffee shot.
And then one day after work, you
had brought your camera, right?
Yeah, I'm just going
to shoot around.
He was like, oh, I know
this rooftop we can go on.
I'm like all right,
let's go, and we went.
The night after that, I
was out and he called me.
And he's like oh, I just
climbed the Williamsburg Bridge.
And I was like, oh, my God!
Yeah, we've been
arrested together.
We were like-- they
already have our names.
But, yeah, like 30
cops and a SWAT team.
Yeah, SWAT too.
They dragged us through
Times Square in cuffs.
Yeah.
I mean, I think at first
they thought we were jumpers.
So when they-- I remember
doing a couple of feet shots,
and then looking down to
the lower part of the roof
and seeing the cops.
I've been shooting
urban exploring
for about two years at most.
It's probably, I guess, the most
exciting thing I've ever done.
That's all I can say, really.
Especially being from Brooklyn,
New York, not many people
explore the city.
So, you know what I do is
I take it into my own hands
and I tend to go places I guess
where I'm not supposed to be.
I actually got into
photography a long time ago,
due to me being a
skateboard filmer at first.
I guess sometimes we
abide by the same rules.
Skateboarding and urban
exploring photography--
when you go to a
certain spot you
can't skate it because there's
usually a security guard there.
When you're skating,
you want to be recorded.
You want to be filmed just
like all the pro skaters.
So when you get into that
idea of wanting to be filmed,
you tend to pick up the camera
and start shooting photos.
And mostly everybody that
I shoot photos with skates.
For a while, me and
my friend [? Naisha ?]
had been scoping out a
432 Park [INAUDIBLE].
And we thought it was
a possible project
that we can maybe sneak into
the building and get to the top.
So we decided to just go for it.
Eventually walked up all
the 90 flights of stairs
and got to the top.
Nothing about the building
really specifically
made me want to climb it.
It was just tall
and it was there.
It was kind of our Everest.
You never know which
doors going to be open.
You can just check a door
and a door just might open.
You might get lucky.
Getting the shot and
knowing that you're
one of the few people
that have been here
is a pretty awesome feeling.
It's an addiction.
You get not only just wanting
to check out new stuff.
It's curiosity, but also
there's like an adrenaline rush
associated with it.
The thrill of going places
where I'm not supposed to go
is the best part about it.
The reason why I explore
is because each place
is relatively easy to
get to, and it just
amazes me that so
many people don't
get to see these places
just because they're
hiding from the public.
I can do it, so I will do it.
"All Points Project" is
a part of Seeker stories.
To see all the news
stories we post here, be
sure to subscribe.
New videos every Tuesday.